I think passion is half the equation but
grit is the other half I think you
definitely have to stick with it hi I'm
Peter yang 29 co-founder of Cokie works
so at pokey works we make delicious
Hawaiian pokey with our fun spin to it
what inspired us to start pokey works
was really just build a demand for a
healthy quick food for people on the go
what I think healthy quick is not just a
trend it's more of a lifestyle that's
you know you see that in every concept
that's successful but also it the
flavors within poke a is very similar to
other foods I've been accepted it's been
part of the American diet so it's it's
just a different vehicle of enjoying
similar foods in the way that people
like you know fast and healthy
[Music]
growing up in high school and college I
worked on my parents restaurants
dishwashing Buster server you name it
I've done it
we thought about pokey works when we
first went to Hawaii me and my brother
and we we ate okay they're like many
people do and from there we tried it
with different things like crushing taro
chips on top and I love carbs so I had
it with some rice and you know from that
point we thought about a kind of a
builder L&Q sr concert for pokey we
opened on a quiet winter December day in
New York City we had a couple people
trickle in not sure what polka was
January our lines just kept building and
building and building and you know me
and my my manager by the time we looked
at each other know like hey this could
work
I live by saying you know do something
uncomfortable everyday so I always look
forward to a challenge I always look
forward to pressure I think it's a
privilege to be pressured and every day
I look forward to what I can learn from
the day and how I can throw what I've
learned working with hourly jobs my
parents I think it comes down to people
and really appreciating your team and it
will let you have on board with um you
know the bus or service or dishwasher
every one of them are crucial components
of the overall operation and success at
the restaurant we want to be continuing
to be recognized as a leader in the poke
a space and every day we fight
[Music]